foreign
Jason Ellis
was on the no jumper show I guess oh wow
so everyone in this sucks yeah
absolutely but
um they're talking about Brendan shop
and this is this is fresh stuff so let's
check it out
after 22. I think it also ties into what
we were talking about earlier when
you're a [ __ ] guy who gets [ __ ] the
mob is out to get you they hate Brendan
Schaub I think Delia got a little bit of
that too because Delia oh they're all in
the same group same with Callan they're
all fitter comedians that uh attractive
and they're walking [ __ ] boners as
soon as you're a hot Rich famous
comedian you are a [ __ ] Target
totally agree why are you laughing well
I'm sorry what was the joke there that
he's laughing at I don't know
that's really what it comes to I mean
it's just we've seen it over and over
and over where it's just like and even
like Brendan's shop like I mean the the
fact that a lot of people think that by
the way now I can see why Lewis is
afraid of this Jason Ellis fella all
right he's not that's Adam no no but I'm
going I'm moving over to Jason Ellis
here in a second I'm actually hold on
he's there he is now I see why why Lewis
is afraid of this Jason Ellis fell okay
he's not joking around I listen to all
those shows I've never laughed once yeah
he's serious
he's not bunny right no he's not a funny
guy he's not supposed to be the the fact
that a lot of people think that he has
money from his family or whatever wait
they do I mean I've seen that floated in
his residence somebody hangs out in the
[ __ ] fighter and the kid read it we
found that out yeah it sure does but
like you guys [ __ ] works these
[ __ ] but what do you like he doesn't
work his
hates you yeah because I [ __ ] open my
[ __ ] dumb ass mouth about [ __ ] why I
was just talking about special I just
not because they did that thing with our
bullying Bobby Lee and Bobby Lee was on
his podcast saying that they threatened
me and when I heard that
I'd already called Cal and text him and
say hey man I think it's really cool
that you [ __ ] just fessed up him and
said because on his podcast he was like
I called him I threatened him I acted
like a [ __ ] [ __ ] I feel stupid I
lost my control and I apologized and I
was like man that was really cool of you
to no that wasn't really cool Jason see
things you don't pay attention because
it's not about skateboarding or [ __ ]
so here's what really happened Callan is
the Fall Guy because that whole New York
Times thing came out and by the way I
think it's all [ __ ] but the
perspective the perception of him was
bad he lost his Goldberg's gig on the TV
show and all that yeah he did it so
whenever something happens in that
Community now he needs to take the heat
for them to be loud back into the group
because he's a soldier dog yeah exactly
dude wears jeans and flip-flops all
right I'm just letting you know the kind
of man he is yeah especially on your
show but then I heard that it was like a
threat of violence and I'm like wait
you've threatened Bobby Lee with
violence why did you say that where did
you once you heard that where did you
who's this [ __ ] Chris halfwick over
here
I don't know who this guy on the right
if someone will tell me and everyone's
gonna this is what always happens with
us someone's gonna know oh yeah that's
Johnny two shoes or whatever or some
[ __ ] no jumper guy I guess who's this
guy I don't know who he is
do you voice this publicly uh I did a
show with a friend that's good friends
with them and I said it in the green
room and now that guy doesn't talk to me
and all those guys unfollowed me on
social media
it's so good who cares
do you care
hey why are you why is this these tough
guys always so gay
you know it's funny I'm always finding
out about these things from other people
yeah it's always other people that have
to say to me hey Mark should you see no
so-and-so and [ __ ] no who knows
you know if you're not gonna be a
hundred percent in support of them
you know I don't I don't I just feel
like that was just I just went out I
just don't want to be in a group where
people do that that just feels like a
situation where Brandon was getting so
much [ __ ] during that that at a certain
point you just really have to kind of
back off and be like all right whatever
like I'm just gonna deal with the fact
that everybody thinks I [ __ ] up in
this situation because I mean I just was
doing the fight companion with Brandon
and I wasn't sure at a certain point if
he was gonna you know invite me to do
[ __ ] like that because of the fact that
I kind of said on one podcast that I
didn't think is special was funny and
then he hit me up to do it and I figured
oh that's cool that he's the type of
person because he still needs Cloud he
still needs gross audience though yeah
you have a bigger audience than him
because he has like 300 000 on his
fighter in the kid and you have 450 so
it's it's a nice little crossover
audience because both people that like
those these kind of shows are [ __ ]
stupid he thinks you know you're a grown
man who likes sneakers he's a grown man
who likes sneakers why not it works
on the right
oh the Danny Mullen
who
exactly oh zj93 said Danny Mullen he's a
[ __ ] okay well thank you thank you ZJ
for doing the producers appreciate it
can I see the thing because mine's yeah
mine's [ __ ] Loco
doesn't hold that against somebody now
the whole Bobby Lee thing was sort of a
much different level of drama whereas
saying you don't think a specialist
funny is one thing but that thought
about the thing was Mother [ __ ] that's a
funny guy I think he's a fun
you think Brandon's a funny guy what's
your favorite hold on hold on that's
what I always say what's your favorite
bit
I always hit people with that [ __ ]
what's your favorite bit Nick Mullins
Nick Mullen not Natick excuse me Nick
swardson's bit that he stole that one
yeah the fajitas bit funny podcast I
think they're all very talented at what
they do I don't have any beef I love
Bobby Lake I don't really even know him
that well but I don't know he's got one
of those things where I just want to
help him which is ridiculous
it happens to Frozen all the time too
because these Asian women like him
because they think they get he could
hold him and like nurse him back to
health
it's like it happens it's a nation's
little Asian boyfriend he thinks I'm
some sort of baby bird that came out of
a tree he's broken he's done like the
bird and Chris Cuomo's yeah that's right
he's as good as dead a woman wants to
adopt him and like feed him soup
like stuff like that you know
kill us because he's a successful he's
got everything but when I heard that
somebody bigger was bullying him that
obviously could beat his ass I'm like
man
that is some
why why would you do that like if
anybody because there are sociopaths or
narcissists you included yes buddy who
was a friend of mine did that that it
was close I would call them be like hey
man like that's what the [ __ ] because
think about what this is this is like a
conversation about geopolitic
geopolitical
yes please no jumper tell us about
geopolitical right a third time let's go
come on guy
we got it political geopolitics and are
they uh he gave up but he bailed he
bailed in the sense of like when do you
escalate beyond words into violence you
shouldn't if it's entertainment
and one good thing you could say about
comedy is that for the most part
throughout College history there's been
very little violence that most of these
problems get worked out with words I'll
tell that to [ __ ] Chris Rock's face
yes or Dave Chappelle or David that's
right you can't tell it to Chris Rock's
face because [ __ ] Will Smith already
did
yeah and that that's a good thing and
you know that's one thing that sometimes
bugs me about rap is you'll be having an
argument with somebody online and then
they basically turn the conversation
into well I could kill you I could beat
your ass or I have more money than you
these are like stupid things that stupid
people say in those kind of
conversations and I think that the
comedy World once they saw that people
were basically like okay I have to ask a
question and I know there's going to be
a bunch of joke answers but I actually
do want a real one after the joke
answers
why is no jumper famous
like what's his claim to say it was he
just interviewed rappers
it's like a Vlad TV kind of guy that's
why he's famous yeah but he's like a
little more face tattooey and gross no I
know yeah yeah I think he was involved
in skateboarding to some degree maybe
but then he was into like the rap thing
and he started interviewing rappers and
he was a guy that like would get these
crazy up and coming rappers on a shot
that's all I know I'm okay because I I
don't know I have no idea and his wife
is gross didn't he show up in our chat
once and you told him to [ __ ] off yeah
and I called him a rapist yeah I
remember that that was funny
that was funny threatening Bobby Lee or
whatever their rights and he was being
nice
yeah he wasn't being mean be nice and I
said [ __ ] off you rapist
we're not we're not we're not this was
back when we had like 50 people watching
that's true
we make friends people [ __ ] imagine if
we didn't fight with everybody bolt
against that right with the Bobby Lee
thing this is how I understand if we
didn't fight with everybody we'd beat
these three [ __ ]
yeah we made the right choice oh yeah I
watched a little bit of Danny mullen's
[ __ ] is it funny do you like a taste oh
it's too it's well it's definitely that
that good good San Francisco comedy
hold on let me I'll [ __ ] heal the
link I didn't know if you were gonna
want it yeah they thought they meaning
shab and Callie yeah that Bobby Lee was
either actively himself
talking [ __ ] yeah just for the audience
might not go right and or he Bobby Lee
was endorsing people talking [ __ ] about
those guys and the reason I'm a little
bit more sympathetic to Shob and Callan
is I've seen the level of hate those
guys get especially shaab and it really
kind of sick there's something fake
puker boys about this guy that's
starting to bug me
but you know what I mean there's
something about you know um you know
like the thing is uh in this situation
what are you what are you doing don't
talk like Mark Harley syndrome for all
the narrative okay we don't let them
censor we don't let them blot out here
is he's taking a black guy to uh an old
slave plantation to talk to ghosts and
we try to make contact baby and if
they're uncomfortable with that well
they can summon some of Louisiana's
finest and we'll talk to the police and
well if we have to Lily I'm sorry offer
you up and we'll omit what she has
lurking between her legs
I'm trying to do a physical embodiment
of herpes right now
oh he's funny
what Royce what's the maiden
Mercy you don't think he's qualified to
talk about comedy he didn't go to the
San Francisco comedy college now did he
no Mark Harley's got this guy beat
is this really what comment I have to
ask yes I know we're old heads in this
[ __ ] now but like is this what comedy is
now well this is better no it doesn't
yeah it does it really does
spirits if you're present anywhere in
this house or on the property I want you
to gather in the living room with us
right now come to us and use Lily like
an antenna an antenna picking up an AM
frequency from The Ether and through her
tell us hey real quick what's the joke
I don't oh he's a goofy guy
he sure is a goofy goofy guy ain't he
he's silly
it's a silly goose before she was
playing [ __ ] Harold Ramis as [ __ ]
Ghostbuster